Donald Trump has been charged with 37
counts in an indictment alleging he
illegally held on to military Secrets
shared them with others and scheme to
mislead the FBI this marks the first
time in history that the US government
has brought federal charges against a
former president as far as the
joke of an indictment it's a horrible
thing here's a breakdown of the charges
and the potential consequences Trump
faces
Federal prosecutors led by special
counsel Jack Smith unsealed a 49-page
indictment on June 9th we have one set
of laws in this country and they apply
to everyone
the indictment alleges the former
president unlawfully retained classified
documents that included information
regarding defense and weapons
capabilities of both the United States
and foreign countries United States
nuclear programs potential
vulnerabilities of the United States and
its allies to military attack it lays
out 37 counts on seven different charges
for counts 1-31 the justice department
breaks down how each count ties to a
specific document retained at Trump's
Mar-A-Lago Resort from number one it's a
document from May 3rd 2018 concerning a
White House intelligence briefing
related to various foreign countries you
go down to the 31st Block in this chart
and its document dated February 2017
concerning the military activity of a
foreign country
the remaining six counts all relate to
Trump's alleged mishandling of documents
as prosecutors claim Trump and his staff
misled Trump's lawyers including Evan
Corcoran into believing that a diligent
search was conducted of the boxes that
were moved from the White House to
Florida and what the indictment details
is this allegation that in early June of
last year Evan Corcoran came down to
Mar-A-Lago planning to essentially comb
through these boxes and not long before
he shows up Trump gives Walt NADA this
personal aid of his this direction to
remove boxes from the storage room and
take them up to his residence neither
Trump nor Walt NADA mentioned all this
movement to Evan Corcoran when he shows
up in early June and goes through these
documents calls the FBI and says come
down and pick these up according to the
indictment Trump endeavored to obstruct
the FBI and grand jury investigations
about his continued possession of
National Security records and that's
really the point they're trying to make
here that Don Donald Trump held on to
incredibly sensitive material that was
Mark's secret Trump has repeatedly
denied any wrongdoing in the handling of
documents at Mar-A-Lago when it comes to
your documents did you ever show those
classified documents to anyone not
really I would have the right to by the
way they would Declassified after not
that I can think of let me just tell you
I have the absolute right to do whatever
I want with him
prosecutors paint a different picture in
the indictment it states an audio
recording of trump indicates he showed
what he described as a highly
confidential Department of Defense
document to people without a security
clearance
Trump said as president I could have
Declassified it and now I can't you know
but this is still secret according to
the indictment the importance of that
meeting and the recording of it is that
Trump demonstrates a little some
mindfulness here that his retention is
not appropriate so that shows a really a
key pillar of any kind of criminal case
which is knowledge and intent that what
knowledge that what you're doing is
wrong and potentially runs afoul of the
law
on June 8th Trump announced on his
social media platform truth social that
he was being indicted and declared his
innocence and they come after
Donald Trump weaponizing the justice
weaponizing using the FBI we can't let
this continue to go on for each count
Trump could receive a maximum 250 000
fine and prison terms ranging from five
years to 20 years but even if tried and
convicted he is unlikely to receive the
top penalties but the reality of federal
cases is that the statutory maximums are
really never what are imposed in cases
it's often a fraction of them
um nonetheless Trump does face the
potential here of a of a prison sentence
of a fine the indictment assures that
Trump's legal trouble will be the focal
point of the Republican presidential
primary contest
it's a sad day for America
to see a former president of the United
States
indicted by the administration
of a sitting president who's also a
potential rival in the upcoming election
Trump said he had been summoned to
appear at the federal courthouse in
Miami on June 13th my office will seek a
speedy trial in this matter
consistent with the public interest and
the rights of the accused
[Music]